bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo où nous allons parler du
grand final de hawkeye le dernier
épisode vient tout juste de sortir et
j'ai quelques trucs à dire sur la série
je préfère vous prévenir davance la
vidéo va spoil complètement la série de
hockey donc vous êtes prévenus mais pas
que puisque il existerait possiblement
certains liens avec spider man aux
arômes donc je vais devoir également
spoil certaines parties du film dans la
vidéo voilà maintenant que c'est dit
nous pouvons commencer premièrement il
serait intéressant de faire un petit
point comics sur ce que nous a proposé
la série comme attendu nous avons eu
l'intégration déco alias maya lopez et
son origin story instauré dans la série
respecte énormément ce qui avait été
établi dans les comics effectivement le
père de maya qui travaillait pour le
caïd a été assassiné sous les ordres de
son patron kingpin a toujours menti à
maya à propos de sa mort afin de la
garder près de lui et la différence
qu'il y as avec les comics c'est que
dans hawkeye il lui fera croire que
c'est le ronin soit barton qui a tué son
père alors qu'à l'origine il lui avait
fait croire que c'était d'art des vies
évidemment comme dans les comics maya
apprendra la vérité et souhaitera se
retourner contre wilson fisk et comme
dans la série elle va lui tirer dessus
mais bien sûr cela ne le tuera pas les
morts hors champ faut toujours se méfier
et les comics dévoile carrément qu'il a
survécu mais bon en vrai c'était évident
marvel n'allait pas tuer le caïd dès son
introduction maya est attendu pour avoir
sa propre série à l'avenir une série du
nom déco son identité d'héroïne en
quelque sorte si l'on suit les comics
après avoir tiré sur kingpin maya va
quitter new york et partir dans une
quête spirituelle afin de trouver un
nouveau sens à sa vie et c'est un peu à
partir de ce moment qu'elle va commencer
à devenir éco ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que maya et vous allez
le voir est connecté à pas mal de
personnages dont notamment matt murdock
avec qui elle partagerait presque une
histoire d'amour les deux personnages
sont très liés dans les comics donc il y
a de très grandes chances que nous
retrouvions d'art des vies dans la série
des cots pour continuer nous pouvons
faire quelques mentions honorables
concernant certains personnages de
comics apparu dans la série par exemple
nous avons eu la présence de kenzy qui
est en fait dans les comics le clown à
l'époque nous savions qu'ils seraient
dans la série possiblement en tant que
l'un des grands méchants puisqu'il est
un vilain plutôt connue doc haye au
final il travaille pour le caïd et c'est
quelque chose qui revient aussi dans les
comics nous avons eu aussi la présence
de pizzas dogues alias le kiki oui lui
aussi fait partie des comics à la base
c'est le chien d'un mafieux et qui au
final va se retrouver dans les pattes de
hawkeye et de kate il y a également la
présence de sword man alias jacques
duquesne marvel a tenté de le faire
passer pour le méchant au début mais
cela ne correspond pas trop à l'essence
du personnage ce dernier c'est avant
tout un fan a de l'âme qui n'est pas
spécialement méchant dans les comics il
a même entraîné aux cayes il a également
aidé les avengers à plusieurs reprises
et personnellement je trouve que
l'acteur du personnage tony dalton là
plutôt bien représentée puisque
swordsman est plutôt théâtrale il vient
à la base un milieu de cirque et de
carnaval donc on retrouve tout ce côté
un petit peu
showman un petit peu ce côté artistique
c'était une bonne représentation petit
point maintenant sur la rolex artefacts
recherché dès l'épisode 1 par la mafia
en survêt et par extension maya et le
caïd cette rolex aurait permis de
révéler l'identité de laura barton la
femme d'occagnes puisque c'est sa montre
et par extension puisque hawkeye est
liée à cette dernière est que tout son
attirail de ronin était aux enchères
avec la montre cela aurait pu révéler
également son identité à terme et
c'était l'objet de la recherche de maya
la rolex permet de rajouter une
backstory alors à barton dont nous ne
connaissions rien de son histoire et il
s'avère qu'au final cette dernière
travaillait pour le shield c'est
certainement là bas qu'elle a rencontrés
clint il ya un lien intéressant à faire
avec les comics puisque cela permettrait
d'introduire le personnage de woking
mockingbird de son vrai nom barbare
amorce et la femme d'okaïdi dans les
comics cette dernière était une agent du
shield et lors d'une mission elle est
tombée dans le coma et a décidé de
profiter de cet accident pour simuler sa
mort est donc arrêtée en quelque sorte
sa carrière pour protéger sa famille ce
sont des éléments qui colle à l'histoire
de laura puisque aux cayes a toujours
caché sa famille avec l'accord du shield
même les avengers dont tonique il le dit
lui-même ignorait l'existence de la
famille d'oka laura anciennement
mockingbird aurait donc raccrocher et
vivrait dans l'anonymat pour protéger sa
famille d'ailleurs elles aident
énormément clint dans la série et a
conscience de son rôle et des risques
qu'ils encourent comme si elles étaient
du métier donc voilà c'est vraiment un
élément sympa pour enrichir l'univers
bon parlons de l'introduction d'ucar
sincèrement c'est la clé de voûte qui va
permettre de relier pas mal de
personnages et pas mal de séries pour
ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas trop le
personnage dites-vous que fisc est un
seigneur du crime c'est un petit peu on
va dire le chef suprême de la grande
majorité des organisations criminelles
il dirige avec une manne faire plusieurs
organisations malsaine il instaure
beaucoup la peur et le respect bref
c'est vraiment un énorme piliers du
crime de plus ce dernier est un
véritable colosse il ne possède pas de
superpouvoirs mais son physique et sa
musculature le rendre capable de se
mesurer à beaucoup de héros dont même
spider man sans oublier évidemment qu'il
est un expert du combat est notamment
spécialisé dans le combat sumo ce qui va
être intéressant avec ce dernier c'est
que là où spider man aux ehome symbolise
une ère de transition avec la première
véritable ouverture du multivers et bien
la fin d'hockey avec l'introduction du
caïd va permettre une transition vers
les oeuvres qui sont un petit peu plus
terre à terre effectivement le caïque
permet de relier tout le monde déjà nous
pouvons prendre le cas de valentina
allegra des fontaines le caïd connaît
les moindres faits et gestes d'eleanor
bishop la mère de kate cette dernière
s'est confronté à hawk eye et lui a
demandé d'oublier la sphère dont kate la
mêlée une affaire qui évidemment il
affirmé c'est impossible qu'il laisse à
côté notamment à cause de la rolex liée
à sa femme par conséquent le caïd a
obligatoirement été mise au courant
puisque ce dernier sait qu'un avenger
s'intéresse de près à son organisation
est sale dérange du coup quelqu'un a été
engagé pour tuer clint et il a été
révélé qu'il s'agissait d léa nord
bishop sauf qu'elle est à nord agit sous
les ordres du caïd ce qui veut dire que
c'est le caïd qui est en quelque sorte
commandité la mort de clint sauf que qui
est allé chercher y est lena pour lui
transmettre la mission de tuer barton
s'est valentina dans la scène post
générique de black widow ce qui veut
dire que valentina est lié de près ou de
loin avec le caïd et valentina pour
rappel à la base dans les comics c'est
une agent triple qui travaille pour le
shield mais qui a également intégré
hydra et qui travaille secrètement pour
léviathan une organisation secrète russe
dans le mc hugh valentina semble jouer
sur plusieurs tableaux comme dans les
comics est temps lié au gouvernement
américain mais agissant dans l'ombre
pour recruter des personnes puissantes
comme john walker par exemple en us
agent ou encore jelena donc si le caïd
possède un lien avec valentina cela veut
dire qu'il possède possiblement à pied
dans le gouvernement et les agissements
de cette dernière personnellement je
reste sûr que valentina possède un lien
avec thunderbolt ross puisqu'elle
cherche à engager des personnes qui dans
les comics forment l'équipe des
thunderbirds donc si kingpin se rajoute
à ça cela permet de tout mais le truc
c'est que cela ne s'arrête pas là
puisque spider man aux arômes entre en
jeu et amène un nouvel élément déjà vous
savez tous kingpin est l'un des méchants
les plus iconiques de spider man et
maintenant ce dernier a été intégré au
mc eu
eh bien il ya deux très grandes chances
que les deux s'affrontent un jour mais
surtout nous savons que depuis le
premier round earth les criminels
s'intéresse de près à la technologie de
tony stark et du qg des avengers et
c'est là que c'est intéressant puisque
dans spider man no way home à cause du
drama médiatique de peter la jeune
araignée est temps lié aux productions
de tony stark notamment concernant son
costume d'iron spyder et plus
particulièrement la technologie est dit
avec les drones et bien le gouvernement
a commencé à mettre son nez dans starsky
industry's et a perquisitionné
énormément d'artefacts provenant de là
bas il ya une scène où nous voyons
justement des camions sortir de ce
parking du striz en portant donc tout le
matériel qu'ils ont pu trouver et nous
avons eu également des plans où nous
voyons des gens analyser les drones qui
ont été utilisés pendant l' attaque de
l'angleterre sauf que ce n'est pas
directement le gouvernement qui est allé
fouiner dans starsky industry's il
s'agit en fait du groupe damage control
par exemple c'est eux qui ont arrêté
peter et qui ont commencé à l'interroger
et c'est eux qui ont perquisitionné
stark industries d'un match control est
une filiale du shield à la base donc
normalement on se dit c'est ok voilà la
technologie de tony stark et des
avengers est normalement en sûreté sauf
que pas vraiment en fait puisque nous
avons déjà eu le cas à plusieurs
reprises de mauvais entités font partie
du shield nous avons déjà eu le cas avec
hydra qui étaient infiltrés ou encore
même la branche du sword avec taylor
hayward dont rwanda vision qui a causé
pas mal de problèmes et bien justement
si l'on suit les comics et c'est quelque
chose qui fait écho à tout ce que nous
avons dit jusqu'à maintenant et bien le
caïd est normalement lié à damage
control il est l'un de ses dirigeants et
ce n'est pas vraiment étonnant quand on
sait qu'on parle d'un des plus grands
chefs criminels du monde et qui est
potentiellement liées aussi avec des
gens du gouvernement comme valentina
mais ce n'est pas tout puisque de par
son statut il y a de fortes chances que
qingping possède aussi des liens de près
ou de loin avec madripoor et par
extension sharon carter qui aujourd'hui
s'est faite gracié et est devenue une
taupe qui va retravailler pour le shield
cette dernière possède donc aujourd'hui
des informations que très peu de
criminels et il est certain que kingpin
fait partie de ses clients mais bon cela
reste de la spéculation dans tous les
cas cela permet également d'intégrer
d'art des villes à la danse ce brillant
avocat qui dans sa série originelle
avait déjà affronté kingpin c'est l'un
de ses plus grands antagonistes
daredevil possède des liens forts avec
de nombreux personnages de marvel comme
eco ou encore spider man et l'avenir est
très prometteur à son égard nous pouvons
penser notamment à la série de chiottes
qui pourraient également être liés à
kingpin avec le drama médiatique de
spider man comme matt murdock à a
commencé à être liée à toutes les
conséquences des problèmes de spider man
et vu que c'est lié aux damage control
est un brillant avocat il va
certainement commencer à s'intéresser à
l'organisation et du coup tout ce qui se
cache derrière tout ça et même si tout
le monde a oublié l'identité de peter
les actes sont là il y aura des restes
de cette histoire la technologie a été
perquisitionné donc voilà si maintenant
doigts commencent à s'intéresser à tout
ça il va forcément finir par tomber sur
des informations concernant kingpin ou
peut-être encore valentina c'est
clairement le début d'une nouvelle ère
pour finir un dernier petit mot sur
spider man même si c'était trop gros
cela aurait été bien que ce dernier
apparaissent dans l'épisode final de
kayes ou du moins dans une scène
post-générique spider man from se
déroule en automne et la fin du film
nous montre peter dans son nouveau
costume à la période de l'hiver ce qui
veut dire que la fin du film se déroule
en même temps que la série aux cayes
puisque nous retrouvons par exemple la
présence de la comédie musicale des
avengers dans les deux oeuvres et étant
donné qu'il est lié de loin pour le
moment aux caïds cela aurait été
intéressant d'utiliser cette future
confrontation à la fin de la série pour
l'avenir surtout que commercialement
parlant spider man aurait permis de
vendre encore plus aux cayes et
inversement puisque si spider man
apparaît dans un nouveau costume avec un
hawkeye qui ne sait plus que c'est peter
parker en dessous les gens se serait
interrogé sur ce qui s'est passé et cela
pousserait certains à voir spider man
noir home et puis ceux qui n'ont pas vu
la série aurait été intrigués de voir le
premier teasing de la suite de
l'histoire de l'araignée ah oui
d'ailleurs j'ai oublié je voulais dire
aussi que j'ai trouvé sympa l'idée de
faire échanger kate et jelena à
plusieurs reprises dans la série nous
voyons qu'elles ont un lien particulier
et qu'elle pourrait même bien s'entendre
mais surtout nous retrouvons clairement
le symbole de l'amitié entre clint et
natacha retranscrit ici du coup avec
kate qui symbolise clint et jelena en
tant que natacha enfin voila je pense
que nous allons nous arrêter là il y
avait quand même pas mal de choses à
dire sur la série je sais pas ce que
vous en avez pensé mais personnellement
j'ai passé un bon moment c'était un bon
divertissement évidemment nous
retrouverons kate bishop et clint dans
des futurs oeuvre du mc hué certainement
je pense dans une oeuvre qui va réunir
pas mal de personnages kate fait
d'ailleurs partie des young avengers et
il commence à y en avoir pas mal d'un
produit dans le mca en vrai de vrai je
suspecte captain america 4 pour amener
une possible réunion lé film captain
america ont toujours réuni plusieurs
personnages et sont notamment également
liée aux cachotteries aux problèmes liés
au gouvernement donc voilà j'espère que
la vidéo vous aura plu en tout cas je
vous invite à voir la dernière sortie
concernant spider man aux arômes et puis
je vous rappelle qu'un trois théories
dédié au film va sortir dans les
prochains jours donc je compte sur vous
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleu un commentaire sur ce que vous avez
pensé de la série et puis surtout à vous
abonner pour ne pas louper les
prochaines vidéos en attendant bah
écoutez cet argot rock je vous souhaite
à tous un très joyeux noël et que le lie
à leur art soit avec vous allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]